l'heure est au bilan de l'année 2010 est
pour la cgt des yvelines environ 150
délégués syndicaux ont échangé sur les
manifestations estivales contre les
ordonnances réformant le droit du
travail
des mobilisations qui n'ont pas touché
le projet du gouvernement
il ya eu des mobilisations
majoritairement soutenu par l'opinion
mais on n'a pas su encore à mener assez
de monde dans les mobilisations et c'est
ce qu'on travaille
voilà d'aller plus au contact des
salariés de rendre tous nos syndiqués
plus acteur de les informer sur les
grands enjeux les mobilisation était
importante
pas suffisamment encore pour faire
reculer le gouvernement
justement ce qui ce qu'il faut c'est
continuer à militer continuer à discuter
avec ses collègues de travail avec sa
famille avec ses amis pour pour faire
comprendre que toute cette situation
toutes ces attaques ne sont pas normales
ce 20ème congrès de la cgt des civils
l'occasion de préparer les prochaines
mobilisations à l'image du jeudi 22 mars
pour protester contre le projet de
réforme ferroviaire avec l'ouverture à
la concurrence ou la fin du statut de
cheminot pour les nouveaux embauchés
et puis le 22 et une convergence de
lutte des cheminots des fonctionnaires
de l'énergie des entreprises
certaines entreprises du privé donc
c'est c'est une étape où on va ensemble
réfléchir comment on donne des suites et
comment on élargit ce que je disais tout
à l'heure
et donc il ya besoin que le 22 mars soit
puissant mais également aussi une
mobilisation des associations d'usagers
et de la population plus largement au
delà des cheminots parce que le rapport
spinetta et ce qui est repris par le
gouvernement c'est une attaque purement
et simplement du service public
ferroviaire
une autre journée de mobilisation est
déjà prévue ce jeudi 15 mars par les
retraités les salariés des ehpad et les
aides à domicile